The mid-1990s, Microsoft started an encyclopedia called Encarta.
They had deployed all the right incentives.
All the right incentives.
They paid professionals to write and edit thousands of articles.
Well-compensated managers oversaw the whole thing to make sure it came in on budget and on time.
A few years later, another encyclopedia got started.
Different model, right?
Do it for fun.
No one gets paid a cent or a Euro or a Yen.
Do it because you like to do it.
Now if you had, just ten years ago, gone to an economist anywhere...
...and said, "Hey, I got these two different models for creating an encyclopedia."
If they went head-to-head, who would win?
Ten years ago, you could not have found a single, sober economist anywhere on planet Earth,...
...who would have predicted the Wikipedia model.